coniuga dune mosse giocherà il pigio
simulator e pigio simulator è un gioco
italy john wesley non so bene come
descrivere questa cosa ma credo che sia
una roba molto più interessante di
gossip l'editore tutte quelle catinali
che in realtà non sono niente
ma questo è un gioco incredibile
l'episodica parejo ct anche le persone
non cup a lui la aia l'episodio
schiantato bochum quale bicchiere best
de merda aiutare le banche che stanno
sul tavolo come le prende
come si può la ayane che porca vacca non
si vola aia maledizione alla vita cosa
sta succedendo aiuto fatemi volare come
siccome sistema
eccolo eccolo è difficile comandarlo
però fidatevi di qualche modo riesco
allora devo prendere gli oggetti con il
tasto hicks quindi prendo la mia vicino
qua ripreso aiart porca vacca non è
facile non è facile ragazzi è un gioco
difficile per l'attenzione che secondo
me l'ha dentro donna output si può anche
a cagare non lo so ecco l'ho preso l'ho
preso
ho rubato la coruna schiscetta ma è
bellissimo c'è un mondo qua è un ct ha
fatto bene comunque ciò anche una vita
ho notato che una vita che stava finendo
prova a tirare in testa sta roba ci
prova con il tasto in maggio la rilascio
eccolo porca vacca l'ho mancato però
posso posso incornarlo dall'alto e rose
di volo in faccia posso ci provo porca
vacca l'ho mancato
non è facile colpire la gente raga è un
gioco delle richiede maestria
ecco lo show è svenuto va bene comunque
penso che è stato creato dagli stessi
creatori di the fish così a fish eye and
fish
io sono pesce anche brad sto morendo di
fame
e come mangio scusami questi va a
mangiare io che find go to pinza ok ma
tipo qua vedo degli hamburger posso
prendere gli hamburger un burrito ho
preso un burrito l'ho mangiato mangiato
no come si mangia siamo sul tavolo fermi
mi sono schianta cosa è successo cosa è
successo
diciamo che a cui mirare cagando
bellissimo e spiegamelo nou dove la
gente vorrebbe che qualcuno ti senti
perso lo aspetta che voglio provare a
beccare quelli che mi ha dato fastidio
all'inizio eccoci
e vabbè vabbè ho pagato la torta alla
panna che cosa è successo
calmi ovviamente perché a gare e devo
ricaricare le batterie mangiare perché
se non funziona
proviamo gli pranzo eccolo l'ho preso a
po su infestare i distretti rubando i
rami e creando inibiva bene aspetta che
prova a lasciare sta roba qua per terra
così me la mangio posso ben affermati
fermati eccoci posso mangiare qualche
modo posso mangiare non so come si
mangia eccoci l'ho mangiato perfetto
sono proprio un signor piccione ragazzi
quello che aspettavo sta giocando a
calcio qua bar a questo tensione ha
parato scusate mi spiace non volevo
scusi ragazzi non è facile colpire la
gente rico le cagate non è semplice
ecco lo popola you man ha sbloccato
darci una cig mentre questi sono morti
comunque vabbè c'è una capra che mi dà
una questo è possibile
ap distrugge tutto quello che poi 90
secondi va bene considerati anche gli
esseri umani fermo prova a fermare
prestazione eccolo 1 e 200 dollari
perfetto la macchina 6 ago sulla
macchina maledizione è difficile
prenderlo
kakà sulla macchina eccolo madonna le
cagate di fuoco harry potter e la
cacciata di fuoco o no va ai ragazzi
impossibile prendere le macchine il suo
gioco è veramente difficile
c'è una parola mi sto impegnando
tantissimo vi assicuro che un casino o
un'ora e mezza per beccarne una ragazza
è veramente difficile guarda davis
cagare un'ora prima
questa secondo capottata posso anche far
fuori i semafori mi sa o no nukes corpo
ho fatto mille dollari
non solo servono i dollari a un piccione
prova nel dubbio usiamo gli obiettivi
festa il parco in festa a piazza in
festa la fattoria in festa la città
vecchia
va bene non ho ben capito come si in
festa però devo mangiare perché sto
morendo la fermi tutti che che cado qua
molto bene farmi mangiare che sono
arrivato non si trattano così gli anni
ma a come vi permettete di picchiare un
piccione pezzenti va giù ok è morto a
posso dire che potrei mangiare adesso
perché se mangio teoricamente mi carico
le cacche comunque devo prima a buttare
giù le persone e poi dopo mangiare
ragazzi è l'unico modo perché se no non
si può fare la prima ad atterrare qua
perfetto è successa europa ci siamo
posso avere anche la bibita fantastico
sono quasi pieno va bene allora devi
infestare i cosiddetti infestare la
piazza lo vedo creare vini ma come
prendo li rami come li prendo i rami non
ho capito questa cosa è difficile o devo
andare sugli alberi immagino ci passa
attraverso il niente alberi posso
entrare dentro la fabbrica vedere cosa
succede alla dentro fabbricati invece no
miti non mi toccare fate schifo
ve lo meritate velo me aiuto mi si è
pagato il piccione aiuto sono dei
problemi
ok a posto niente come non detto avuto
un momento di esorcismo o saprò blu
le fattorie o mi sono caricato sul mio
stesso cibo va bè fa niente
l'aspettativa java qualcuno sta
lavorando visto posto tutti che mangiano
hai visto la capra si l'ho vista devo
capire come infestare le robe perché non
sorprendere i ramoscelli sarà meno ninfe
stiamo chi se ne frega però porca vacca
volevo farlo gioco anch'io raga non sono
per niente falloso
meno male che non ho beccato nessuno che
questa faceva malissimo new left and the
level cosa vuol dire no vabbè se esci
dal livello muori va bene pressioni
button to join perché può giocare anche
i più persone ok va bene già a volare
con un piccione un problema figurati in
multiplayer sul die presse 2 gage ap
john miller vision a vedi vedi che puoi
vedere 2 mar due farini di e come faccio
a fare il video scusa amico ned sticks è
ok ma dove li prendo si sticks c'è un
modo per questa è la vista i piccioni
ragazzi dal mondo nel mondo i piccioni
vedono così non fatemi domande perché
non so come sia possibile ma vedono così
vision grava steak and drop it ok ma
dono prendo lo stick le gamin eccolo
eccolo qua ne ho preso uno che me lo
sono mangiato però va bene prende un
altro anche quello ok questo l'ho preso
e non è scomparso va bene
ness adesso devo andare lì e buttarlo
giù va bene
mesto è comunque ragazzi era un
giocatore del milan ok devo gravare più
si va bene e che non l'avevo proprio
visti per terra assistito che quindi
c'era un modo ci siamo ragazzi siamo
messi 2
teoricamente ancora uno è in festa la
piazza questo dovrebbe essere
l'obiettivo almeno del primo livello poi
non lo so eccoli questa fionda questa
pianta bravo quest'altro il tronco e
otto volte me come faccio a trascinarlo
impossibile o più solido il nido ora
chicago dentro lei ex a posto tieni le
tue nuove al caldo va bene ma devo stare
intorno
aspettare chi si schiudano musica teano
piccioni ragazzi piccioni che fanno
casino bellissimo siete i miei figli
fate bordello
spero faccia casino io devo dargli da
mangiare pure vabbè ci manca solo questo
tratto del frappè fra perché fa
benissimo agli dèi ai neonati piccioni
perfetto toller frappe cosa volete di
più
cosa volete più le fave volete giocare a
fort night ma non capito o merda dai
miei figli successo dai raga di semi e
schiattata famiglia la vedeva niente
nora che non ho capito i miei figli sono
implosi dal nulla
boh va bè ragazzi un gioco molto triste
questo tra queste the training non so
c'è un punto limite dove posso smettere
di volare che poi caso direttamente no
posso volare fino all'infinito ma perché
ci stai
[Musica]
you left the level a se vai troppo sulla
ecco niente a posto va bene finisce
anche con la musica perfetta
signori questa è la peugeot simulator si
è spenta la luce
spero che video vi sia piaciuto a me
molto perché mi da questi giochi mi
danno la proprio la voglia di continuare
a fare video mi fa piacere che da quando
è nato con simulator e stiamo parlando
di sei anni fa più o meno non è che i
giochi sono si sono diversificati non
hanno continuato ad essere così il che è
bellissimo vi fa capire quanto
apprezzato il mondo degli indie
meraviglioso mi sia piaciuto ragazzi in
estate mi piace un commento su questo
gioco su cosa ne pensate
viva i piccioni ragazzi dei piccioni sia
già dalla campanellina se vi è piaciuto
perché è molto importante così le
notifiche e giriamo al prossimo video
come sempre bei ragazzi
[Musica]